[موسيقى]
مساء الخير هندي باي باي يعني ايه يعني
الهند والصين اخوه هذا الشعار الذي ظهر في
اول الخمسينات وتحول الى اغنيه شهيره يمكن
ان يكون نقطه انطلاق لفهم العلاقات
الهنديه الصينيه الملتبسه والمتبره منذ
اكثر من 70 عاما العلاقه بدات بامان ورديه
في التاخي والتعاون ثم تحولت الى توتر في
حرب ساخنه سنه 62
فمنوشات على الحدود بتدور من وقت لاخر
اخرها في مايو الماضي وما زال في اللحظه
اللي انا باكلم حضراتكم فيها هناك الاف من
الجنود الصينيين والاف من الجنود الجنود
في مواجهه بعضهم البعض على خط حدودي مختلف
عليه فوق جبال الحملايه هو الخلاف او
الصراع الهندي الصيني على ايه على ماذا
يتصارعان
الحقيقه انه الخلاف في السبب المباشر له
بين البلدين الاكبر في العالم السبب
المباشر له هو الحدود وتحت كلمه مباشر ضع
عده خطوط لان هناك اسباب اخرى اعمق واقوى
من السبب المباشر
البلدين بينهم خط حدودي بيمتد على حوالي
4000 كيلو متر لكن معظم هذه الخط الطويل
جدا متنازع عليه والنزاع بيتركز تاريخيا
على نقطتين واحده في الغرب واخرى في الشرق
اللي في الغرب هي منطقه سكايتين واللي في
الشرق هي منطقه ارمشال باراديش الصين
بتقول الهند انت تحتلينا
32,000 ميل مربع اللي هي تقريبا منطقه
ارمشال باراديش اللي هي ولايه الان في
الهند والهند بتقول للصين وانت تحتلينا
حوالي 17,000 ميل مربع في
اسكاي تشن
بالقرب من اقليم او منطقه كشمير الكبرى زي
كثير من الخلافات الحدوديه اللي بنسمع
عنها بتعود دائما لحقبه الاحتلال
البريطاني اللي حاول ترسيم الحدود بين
الهند التي كان يحتلها وبين الصين ودوله
التيبات حين كانت مستقله قبل ان تبتلعها
الصين وحاول هذه المحاوله في نهايه القرن
ال 19
يعني 1800 وشويه ولكن لم ترضى الدول
الثلاثه بالترسيم الذي وضعه البريطانيون
وظل الخلاف موجود اثناء الاحتلال وبعد ذلك
مع استقلال الهند سنه 47 تقدرت الخلافات
الحدوديه مره اخرى لكن لا لكنها لم تكن
خلافات يعني ملتهبه وظلت خلافات هادئه لكن
الاحداث الاخرى وخلافات الدولتين تحديدا
الهند والصين على ملفات اخرى هو الذي الها
من خلاف الحدودي سنه 54 وتحديدا في اكتوبر
54 كان في لقاء مهم بين الزعيم الصيني
ورئيس الوزراء الهندي نهره وفي اللقاء ده
اللي اتكشفت يعني تفاصيله لاحقا بيكشف لك
كثير من يعني مسار العلاقه فيما بعد ما
كانت وجهه نظره انه تستقطم الهند باعتبار
انه الهند والصين دولتين من دول العالم
الثالث
عانوا كثيرا جدا من اذلال الاستعمار
الغربي
لكن الحقيقه
البلدين بعد هذا اللقاء ووقتها كانت بقى
ظهرت شعار تشيلي هندي باي باي ان احنا
اخوه لكن بعد كده تقاطعت قصائد دولتين
وتعرضت مصالحهما ورؤيتهم للعالم بشكل كبير
رؤيه ما ورؤيه الصين ان الهند مثل كل دول
العالم الثالث يجب ان تكون في صف واحد
وتحالف واحد تقوم بثوره ضد المستعمر
الغربي طبعا تحت قياده الصين الشيوعيه
الهند كان لها وجهه نظر مختلفه تريد ان
تنقى بنفسها عن المستعمر الشرقي والمستعمر
الغربي وقادت حركه سميت وقتها بحركه عدم
الانحياز اللي انضمت اليها عدد من دول
المنطقه هنا ده كان اول احباط في العلاقه
بين الهند وبين الصين ثم تعدلت مسارات
الخلافات اول خلاف بارز كان الخلاف على
قضيه الطيبات اخذ الدوله مستقله الهند
الصين كان رايها انها ليست مستقله هي جزء
من الاراضي الصينيه التاريخيه ودخلتها
بالقوه بالفعل سنه 50
وابتلعت منطقه التهيبات منطقه التيبات
اهلها امو بانتفاضه بدات الانتفاضه وتصعرت
من سنه 56 ل 59 عندما تمكنت القوات
الصينيه من قمعها تماما وفرت ضلاله لاما
اللي هو زعيم التيبات الروحي الى الهند
الامر الذي اثار غضب الصينيين واعتبروا ان
الهند تقوي
معارضين ومنشقين ومنفصلين يسيرون القلاقل
داخل الاراضي الصينيه وعلى الخلفيه دي
بدات المشاكل الحدوديه تصعد وتحديدا في
منطقه سكاي تشل يعني بالقرب من منطقه
كشمير اللي هي اخطر منطقه في العالم كما
شرحنا في حلقه سابقه عن كشمير لانها بتبقى
على الحدود بين الصين والهند وباكستان
وبدات الحرب سنه 62 اللي انتصرت فيها
الصين بشكل واضح واستمرت 32 يوم
ثم قالت الصين علمت الهند درسا ثم انسحبت
او عاده الى ادراجها دون تغيير كبير في
الحدود
ما اريد ان اقول ان الخلاف الحدودي لم يكن
هو المحرك الاساسي للحرب بين البلدين ولكن
كانت الحدود بتجتهد حين تلتهب الخلافات
الكلام ده كان في الماضي لكنه لايضا لم
يتغير في الحاضر في السنوات ال 10 الاخيره
ثارت خلافات حدوديه مختلفه
2013/2017 مؤخرا في مايو 2020 وفي الوقت
الجاري لكن برده المتتبع له العلاقه بين
البلدين هيجد انه عاده للالتهاب على
الحدود بيعكس خلافات كبيره بعيدا عن قضايا
الحدود
هم البلدين في الوقت الحالي مختلفين على
ايه لو عاوز تلخص الخلاف فتجد انه خلاف
طبيعي جدا
ناتج عن الحجم الضخم جدا للبلدين
باعتبارهم الاكبر في العالم قوتين
نووييتين والاهم انهما جارتان بيتشاركان
4,000 كيلو متر
وكلاهما خصوصا في السنوات الاخيره لديه
طموح كبير ان يصبح قوه عظمى في هذا العالم
الصين طبعا بدات مشورها لصعود العام عالم
مبكرا وعندها رؤيه انها لازم تسيطر او
تبسط نفوذها على على الاقل مراتب وراها
وخصوصا اسيا الجنوبيه اسيا الجنوبيه دي
اللي بتعد اهم منطقه همم يعني اهم مناطق
النفوس الهنديه دي منطقه الهند ما يحدث ان
الصعود الصيني يعني بالنسبه بالنسبه لها
ان هي تتولى في اماكن بتعتبر اماكن نفوذ
طبيعيه بالنسبه للهند ناخذ امثله لا تعد
ولا تحصى مثلا سريلانكا لتقع على بعد
حوالي 40 50 كيلو متر من الشواطئ الهنديه
كانت منطقه نفوذ هنديه لكن اللي حدث في
السنوات الاخيره ان الصين تمكنت من النفاذ
الى سريلانكا وبدات في التعاقد على بناء
ميناء بتشك الهندي
قاعده عسكريه
وبتتدخل من خلال يعني بت نفوزها على
الحكومه السريلانكيه والدخب السيريلانكيه
من خلال القروض ومشروعات البنيه التحتيه
اما نشوف منطقه مثلا زي نيبال اللي كانت
تقليديا ايضا منطقه نفوذ هنديه هنجد انه
نيبال بدايه من 2015 اصبحت واقعه تحت
النفوذ الصيني ومش بس واقعه تحت النفوذ
الصيني يعني لم تكتفي الصين فقط بتقليص
النفوذ الهندي هناك ولكنها ايضا شجعت
نيبال او دعمتها في دعمه نيبال يعني في
اثاره خلاف حدود قديم مع الهند منطقه
بوتان مملكه بوتان دي منطقه مملكه صغيره
جدا مساحتها حوالي 38,000 كيلو متر مربع
وعدد سكانها
حوالي يعني 3/4 مليون 750,000 هذه المملكه
الصغيره جدا الضعيفه جدا حظهار انها تقع
بين العملاقين وهناك خلاف حدود بين الصين
وبوتان بتقول انا منطقه دقلاندي تابعه ليا
وليست مشكله منطقه دقلان دي انها قريبه
جدا من وادي في اقصى شمال الهند بيسموه
عنق الدجاجه حيوي جدا للامن القومي الهندي
احتلت الصين هذه المنطقه معناها ان هي
بتعرض امناء القومي الامن القومي الهندي
للخطر نتيجه وجود الصين على بعد يعني
امطار من حدودها وبالتالي فار الخلاف
الحدودي اللي موجود سنه 2017 لما الهند
دافعت بجنودها ان هم يزيحوا الجنود
الصينيين بايديهم حتى لا يقيموا جسرا او
طريقا ارادوا بنائه هناك
بالمناسبه من الامور الملفته جدا للخلافات
الحدوديه بين الدولتين
نصائح شهدت حرب ساخنه سنه 62 لكنها كانت
قصيره 32 يوم فقط ثم مناوشات مستمره لكن
هتجدوا ان هي هذه المناوشات باقل تكلفه
بشريه ممكنه من سنه 75 والى الان لم يقتل
جندي الصيني او هندي واحد بطلقه نار من
الطرف المعادي لان الدولتين قرر ان لا
يستخدمه النار ابدا
وبتقتصر المناوشات الحدوديه على الايدي
يعني بالايدين والركلات كانها حرب شوارع
كل طرف بيحاول ان يزيح الاخر دون استخدام
للنيران طبعا لسبب مفهوم او لاكثر من سبب
الحقيقه اهمهم ان الدولتين النوويهتين لا
يريدان الاشتباك في حرب قد تجر العالم الى
كارثه اثنين انه حقيقه يعني شيني هندي باي
باي يعني هم فعلا اخوه بس مش بالمعنى
المثالي قوي يعني ليس بين الهند والصين
الضعائر هي الكثيره التي مثلت بين الصين
واليابان او التي بين الهند وباكستان
بينهما خلافات ومنافسه ولكن لا توجد
باستثناء حرب اكتوبر 62 القصيره لا توجد
ضرائن كبيره بين الصين والهند ولكن توجد
منافسه متزايده
اذا في سبب الخلاف الاساسي هو صعود
البلدين ورغبه كل منهما ان يلعب دورا اكبر
في محيطه وعلى الساحه الدوليه
اكبر الخلافات بين الدولتين طبعا هو
العلاقه بين الصين وباكستان من الناحيه
اللي الهند بتعتبرها اكبر خطر عليها لان
باكستان في الد اعداء الهند
صعود العلاقه بين الهند بين الصين
وباكستاني يمثل خطر كبير جدا على الهند
الخوف الاكبر للصين هو تقارب بين الولايات
المتحده والهند الاولاد المتحده لا تخفي
رغبتها ان تكون الهند هي
مخلب القط يعني اللي همم يلجم الصين بتعمل
انه الهند بدعما من الولايات المتحده يمكن
ان تكون قوه مكافئه في جنوب اسيا تحد من
تطلع الصين ورغبتها في ابتلاع كثير من
مناطق النفوس في اسيا الجنوبيه ومن اسيا
الجنوبيه تنطلق الى اماكن اخرى من العالم
الخوف الاكبر للصين انه
ب- بتعمل من الولايات المتحده تقيم الهند
تحالف مع استراليا واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه وطبعا للولايات المتحده لمحاصره
الصين كل مكان شكل الصراع بين الدولتين
بياخذ اشكال متعدده لا نهايه لها منها
مثلا الصراع على تطوير الاساطير كل دوله
على قدم وساق في محاولتها لتطوير اساطير
تجوب المحيط الهندي وتجوب بحر الصين
الجنوبي والمحيط الهادي هناك الصراع
التكنولوجيه وخصوصا في المجال العسكري
والاتصالات اللي اطلقت الصين قمرا تطلق
الهند قمرا من اطلقت الصين صاروخا لاسقاط
الاقمار الصناعيه
تلاحقها الهند باطلاق صواريخ قادره على
اسقاط الاقمار الصناعيه همم ان طورت الصين
صواريخ تط الهند صواريخ مماثله تسبق الصين
والهند تلاحق الحقيقه اماكن الصراع
يعني مجالات بين البلدين الاكبر في العالم
كثيرا جدا في هذه المرحله
بدال الصراع يميل الى كفه الصين اللي
ناتج المحلي الاجمالي لها خمس اضعاف
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للهند وبالتالي
حجم الانفاق العسكري يعني بيعكس هذه
الفجوه الكبيره في 2017 الارقام المعلنه
الصين ان فقط اكثر من 150 مليار دولار على
ميزانيه التسلح فيما انفقت الهندي 52
مليار دولار فقط على ميزانيه التسلق
البلدين في صراع المحموم لتامين
احتياجاتهم من النفط لانهم اكبر
مستوردين وليس مستهلك اكبر مستهلك للطاقه
في العالم هو الولايات المتحده لكن امريكا
لديها مواردها المحليه
بالنسبه للهند والصين عندهم موارد محليه
اقل خصوصا الهند وبالتالي هما ثاني
والثالث اكبر يعني مستهلك لكنهما اول
وثاني اكبر مستورد للبترول
وتحديدا من منطقه الخليج ومن منطقه الشرق
الاوسط ولذلك
الجزء من تنافس البلدين هو سرعهما على
النفوذ واقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه وسياسيه
واقتصاديه مع دول افريقيا ودول الشرق
الاوسط وتحديدا دول الخليج في المرحله دي
الصراع بيقتصر على الاقتصاد وعلى الصفقات
وعلى معامل تكرير البترول وعلى تامين عقود
بترول هنا وهناك في العراق ومع السعوديه
والكويت وعمان وعلى الموانئ اللي
بيتصارعوا عليها في باكستان وفي ايران وفي
سلطنه عمان لكن خلال سنوات قليله جدا
خصوصا مع الانسحاب الامريكي من كثير من
المساح العالم سوف تسعى الصين والهند
للاعب دور اكبر ومن بين هذه الادوار التي
سوف تلعبها هو الدور العسكري في منطقه
الخليج العربي في المحيط الهندي وفي منطقه
الشرق الاوسط لانه البنات المتحده الان
بتلعب هذا الدور حينسحب
لن تتردد الصين والهند في محاوله ملء
الفراغ لان امن هذه المنطقه مهم جدا جدا
للامن القومي لكل من الصين والهند ولذلك
سوف نشهد تصاعدا كبيرا جدا للصراع بين
الهند والصين على منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ومعهم ان شاء الله تكون لنا حلقات اخرى
نرصد فيها هذا الصراع اشكركم والى اللقاء